her foot's asleep it's completely asleep
both of them are yeah that's good
[Music]
actually Purge that's the first one cuz
this is the first Purge citizens of the
reject Nation it's time to
purge for the first time ever cuz it's a
prequel yeah and I didn't know that I
just thought it was going to be like a
fourth Purge it's Purge for the first
Purge which isn't confusing at all and I
am very excited for this but I am
curious how The Purge came to be because
I thought we already knew about The
Purge during the first film like how it
came to be but now we'll see really how
did terara come to be now we're going
deep I don't think anybody wants to know
the answer to that question we shouldn't
do the birds in the bee talk for The
Purge movie no I'm like that person like
the Terminator like I landed in in in
Asphalt like in a parking lot and I came
out of a you know a cocoon and then I
was here but not powerful like
Terminator and then people were just
like Oh
weird you know so I don't I don't know I
really don't know yes and Betty and
Veronica Romy and Michelle Tara and Roxy
in the house ohma Louise you just said
Louise you just shouted Louise I just
don't get it my brain y'all you purged
Thelma oh that was good that was good
rocks I purge them if you liked it like
this video comment subscribe bring the
Bell
ring the bell also thank you so much to
every single one of you guys who rented
always Lola it's the new movie that I'm
in it's all over the place and I have
been seeing you guys show up and show
out you've been writing to me on all the
socials telling me that you're liking it
which is just like the best thing for an
actress ever good cuz the validation cuz
we just so badly need it in our souls
it's the thing we live for and also
thank you to prepper for helping us edit
these videos down if you guys want more
of it if you are the sexiest of super
sexy people then please go to p patreon
become a patron and sync up with your
own copy so you can do a watch along
with us over there Greg and John cover
several shows exclusively with
highlights and watch alongs included
perch y'all ready for this that was good
acting right then maybe Lola too they
make it oh yeah that's my audition right
there still
Lola stilla forever Lola all right see
you guys on the other
side
who are you angry at
everybody everyone I called it what do
you do when you get angry I pipe up I
what pipe up my lungs were small do you
have an outlet to release this anger if
you can't get high no I want a l sh this
is a PSA
dare this this
deep I have for everyone everything just
to purge wa okay Purge interesting term
you may have a chance to purge
soon the first Purge all right America
stock market down another 2,000 points
and the largest drop in its history
mortgage crisis worse than 2 I need a
job I'm the
[Music]
99% but why would the purge help with
opioids maybe if you kill somebody you
won't need Narco
from personal
experience I
disagree as your elected president with
my fellow new founding fathers we make
this promise we will revive this country
we will do whatever it takes to let you
dream again make America dream again oh
God it's so scary all right Staten
Island let's go two days before the
experiment
experiment okay hello 25 million ABS oh
oh that's the guy um that's the guy from
insecure oh he's cute yeah he's hot oh
yeah insecure yes this night of
legalized crime The Purge conflict
between anti- Purge protesters and Purge
supporters broke out early today in
North Carolina raise up Staten Island
The Chosen site has become the focus for
the entire world Isaiah Tower made the
news he looks so young I know goes on to
be cyborg maybe this is his an origin
story this [__] experiment really
happening
I the first Purge would be so confusing
also might be the first time that I
would have to go buy a weapon just to
like be like I don't know I'm scared
protect myself I would want just a taser
because taser would be great yes
otherwise you hurt yourself pepper spray
taser pepper spray taser is good keep a
knife on hand just in case if you remain
on Staten Island during the experiment
you will receive monetary compensation
of $5,000 we would implant a tracking
device in your arm release your anger
you mean can kill someone if you feel
compelled what huh okay are signing up
to participate in the experiment they
are where's Pete Davidson we're on
Staten Island I'm like H
oh it's a weird joke to determine their
mental status before they Purge and they
will be evaluated again after the
experiment how do you evaluate that the
protesters are out they have their signs
and their fist are raised they are
against the Purge experiment that is
happening this is wrong walk away from
their money I honestly could see
something like this happening though if
you need the money yeah five grand to
stay home and be like hopefully you can
keep yourself safe it's good amount of
money it's the chip though Purge was
analyzed for years we allowed Island
citizens to vote on participation they
voted yes a lot of those people felt
coerced by the fact they don't have
money and you're offering money that
line was amazing yeah it's a double like
I don't they don't have money and you're
offing the money
behavioral scientists who actually came
up with this whole experiment mer to yes
there we go wow the hair the NFA knew
that we the impoverished would stay if
there was monetary gain these signs are
very well painted yeah yeah they are
most protest signs are not that easy to
read no it is people on cardboard
scribbling with their messy ass
handwriting there are artists here in
Staten Island everybody want to be a
gangster you really think the these
regular folk going to pop each other
like gangsters when the time com I don't
think they want to be it am I the
luckiest man in the world three kings At
Your Service nah we the three wise men
who you was
kidding yeah it's there's so many why
can't I remember everybody's name ever
Greg doesn't let us look that up I
remember none of them question is are we
going to be the Christians or the Lions
Gladiators or the slaves GL are lions
maybe he meant like Christians are like
Jesus and lions are like lions to
participate a protest still fighting a
good fight woman oh I see sounds like a
dream come true for a man in your
business You Got Me Wrong in this one
now I don't know what it is when I don't
know exactly what something is I don't
trust it I just have to say her hair
looks amazing there's like little tiny
braids underneath the big braid that's
something so interesting I was just
thinking how perfect her face is dude
she's a very beautiful woman yes she is
and her hair is fire it's the face for
me hey yo pocket that money quick son
your sister know you here you're better
than this son good point so what do you
think he's doing dealing opioids I just
my brain just went automatically to
drugs but you're probably right about
the what you need Skeletor yeah I smell
your sweat innocent isah just fresh
fresh you talking about get my biz with
your fine ass sister hey y move on my
face man uhoh see that's what the doctor
ordered and I'm the practicing
practitioner oh oh oh my
god oh he just start firing oh my
goodness come on come cut
me oh boy The Purge has started the
purge hasn't started though too early
it's too early he can still get arrested
what you all do you get hurt or you die
I lose money and I don't lose money I
believe you I want a purge man for the
first time in my life I could be a la by
the
citizen oh okay girls laying down some
power oh what that was so quick if you
so much as blink Blazer will remove the
skin from your face Fatman she does
exactly what I say you know why we're
family I put food on her table my bad D
I'll stay home okay they're showing us
who's in charge is he purg daddy this
time or no I guess I mean he I mean he's
got a purge daddy body but we're not
sure yet he's putting food on the table
that's daddy stuff yeah it
is
I Jesus Christ what happened to your
neck that was a quick cut there's a a
lot of like jarring editing choices in
this probably on purpose but it's
putting me on edge we on edge here eyes
the eyes your eyes in right to ASAP now
me you everybody know you tossing the S
you ain't talking but you telling me
everything man let's pay attention
wait he's also a basketball coach from
the top oh he is okay so he deals drugs
and he coaches basketball do I cut the
[__] I need to talk to you now is that
her brother who's this guy to her what
are you talking about who's this guy to
her lover wait she was the one in Next
Level you think X okay yeah for sure
that's why they're pissed and she's
pissed at him because her brother got
cut yeah well I know that oh right I was
like oh is that her other brother I
would never let Isaiah get anywhere
close to the business you know that he
wanted to make life a little bit easier
for us with some extra and I told you I
would give you money for that stop I'll
never take your blood money you know
that oh yeah I totally just blanked out
on the conversation they had when she
was protesting now okay I'm with it now
I swear to God my struggle is real
you're
good oh man so as that fiend W your
brother I'm I'm going take care of that
what you going to do you going to hurt
him kill him all right come on I don't
know cuz that's your answer right that's
who you are
during The Purge Now The Purge is one
day you destroy this community 364 days
a year okay what about on leap
year what about on Christmas man I knew
in love years ago had courage and at
soul I missed that
man make out now I know I know I know
dude come on there's two really
good-looking people I'm angry you want
to release that anger no I need to the
official flower of the experiment they
represent rebirth in the Box you have
recording lenses should you choose to
actively participate wear them on the
evening and they'll document everything
you do wa as I said greater
participation yields greater financial
compensation dude that means you get
more money if you kill more people or at
least that's what they're claiming yeah
that's
insane the colors were bright before
yeah it's CP a baby military nobody
knows what to expect must the most
tension yeah because they can't do
anything but they have to like I guess
if you didn't cross the border before
the prayer then they're not going to let
you through why can't we just stay home
Selena because we can okay this is the
safest place in the neighborhood also
famous she is also famous Pastor om
opened up the church to everyone okay we
got CS there's going to be security at
the door food yeah I think you might be
right the church would be a Target
pastor's a wonderful man but his Tans
bore me to death it's a goddamn snooze
okay he's saying godamn in the church
that's godamn crazy I like her yeah me
too already in Brooklyn sis a block away
from Uncle Uncle T's Place um I I got
the last bus off the island I wish you
were with me why is he lying I was
hoping she could hear it in his voice
and be like I I don't believe you right
I just I'm I'm a block away from uncle's
place I wish you left that's a you track
is mother F and fall this is 18 you got
to find my friends
exactly I would not put those contacts
in that is a way for the government to
know exactly what you're doing that is
crazy I would not get microchipped but
honestly $5,000 would be life-changing
for me as well so I do feel
this I would put the contacts in
immediately and say chip me up and then
be like can I get half half the money
now imagine what it would be like to be
able to comfortably pay rent oh amazing
it would be amazing
or just to pay all the bills and like
not have a credit card that I am like
ohx oh it's p pass to still oh nobody
else paid that off for
me Serpent
eyes okay this is an intense little
walkway this yeah all right that was his
red carbon moment now we're going to
take you live to the White House where
president Bracken will address the
citizens of Staten Island and the nation
no one speaks in like a New York accent
and I'm like isn't Staten Island
citizens of Staten Island will be part
of something that could bring about
great change we are all Staten Islanders
tonight that's not how that works oh
this is taking a minute to get into The
Purge yeah this is not a test this is
your emergency BR that looks different
from when it was weapons of class four
and lower have been authorized for use
during the EXP experiment all crime
including murder will be legal for 12
continuous hours God that's insane may
God be with you
all God the fact that people stayed I
just I don't know anymore I'm like
legitimately a little like ah it's like
scary hearing it some of them didn't
even get chipped they just didn't want
to move their drug money right but I
have a feeling that some of his people
did need money so they did get chipped
and then might be how they get caught or
something I don't know okay cuz they
don't all have the contacts right the
people at the church they must have they
have chips though they chips you only
put the contact in if you're planning on
purging got it the chips is how they
know that you didn't leave the island
okay is that a drone can't how big giant
drone why does it look that big against
that
building what oh don't get snippy with
that gun you probably only have six
rounds in there buddy where is he right
now the
prison no I think he's like in the
building that he lived in let's bring
that energy to this movie yeah
energy whip it whip it whip it nobody
goes sleep yet we're about to
perge oh my God they are ready why do
they have crazy dolls in the thing I
don't know they said everybody made fun
of them their whole lives it because you
push doll now why yeah what is going on
with the dolls oh oh this Wolverine
injection style this has got some
superhero stuff in
it
Purge please Fortress this is Amateur
hour do you know I've been starting all
the other videos with Purge it doesn't
play the same really that's hilarious
skeletor's Pur is on oh I did not know
that that was that guy name until right
now what skor you've been charging me
money to take out my money I want my
money back I think people haven't tried
that before Budd oh that got me no
Fortress oh he just killed them that was
quick is this the first of the night
number one I wonder if different colors
mean different things yeah in the in the
contact yeah cuz his were blue before
and then it's orange okay so maybe
purple when it's murdering I don't know
I don't know my L y'all
gots yo from tonight yeah but they all
have it so they all got chipped from
that one just all [__] why is it so hot
in there they're sweating so bad it's
just so weird cuz none of you guys trust
the government so putting these cont
things in there yeah this is the first
Purge of the
evening purple is surrounding screen
so okay get it out there guys it's so
weird so weird okay get get it out there
get it out where so weird like to the
yeah I guess to be like here's our first
murder cuz maybe that means other people
will start to do it
yeah oh that's creepy what is that a
person waving yeah I guess like an owl
what's going on
here uh oh God that's a creepy
shot they love the rooftops in The Purge
and I support it cuz the last one they
were on the roof remember yeah but it
makes sense you want to get Higher
Ground yeah totally you about purging
better Advantage yeah remember Purge
emotions I don't need to be on a roof
for that if you need company we got the
girls on the way I'm not interested yeah
cuz he's in love with the hot girl do
you think you ever would have purged no
no I found Pastor secret stash in his
office he's got a whole bar up there are
you kidding me thank the Lord monopo is
not going to get me through this night
oh heck yeah would you purge I mean if I
was really like broke broke I'd have to
be in a real bad way if it was the first
Purge you maybe would I might try to
like take money from a bank or something
yeah totally I I think I would so scary
to say that murder is legal and you're
just like I could be at the ATM someone
just [__] stabs me and that's it I
wouldn't do it either but to know that
you could CH to have money to get money
I agree with that from the government
from the banks not from people but like
we would do it right we get Medieval
Times I'd be like cover me in all that
stainless steel gear Jew
all of it like cover me up I'd find like
old school armor and then I would go out
to steal
money it's weird to me people are just
in ordinary clothes it's a
bomb that's why they are smart oh but
it's fireworks in
them oh they're nuts I love them it was
kind of funny that's that is pretty I
mean it that it was just fireworks in
them so couldn't like hurt someone it
could burn you a little bit but no if I
could kill somebody for sure if it if it
did it if you did it right it was like
oh yeah yeah but it didn't and they were
giggling I kind of like they're they're
partying man oh my God see that kind of
stuff would freak me out yeah so I just
anybody walks by they're like ready to
kill you right I wouldn't do it but just
like oh man to be able to have money you
stand in my way I will you up
okay y
whoa oh this guy do yo I say you chill
it's me CS damn K Scar the [__] out of
me son why does he have no contacts yeah
oh I see you all here looking for
Skeletor ain't you mother made you look
like a little [__] now you trying to
save some face it's a purge party down
the block the hell is a purge party yeah
what is a purge party look at this some
kind of block
party H hey girl hey it would be like
rage City at first right right
yeah I still would be so scared that
someone would be there and they'd just
set off a bomb and kill us all because
you just could do that this is very
disturbing but it is what we it's still
the same one what we are looking at here
is actually legal surprised there's
still only been one murder as of now but
they've caught with the eye things yeah
true so many of them aren't wearing them
yeah cuz then if they if they do Purge
they can but they're not going to be
paid for it cuz it's not recorded right
so it's the first kill of the night 20
million views already but I'm out I'm
going to go find that psycho hey yo y yo
careful son that crazy well he's just
going to go by himself you guys aren't
going to be like all right man what are
they going to do go with him yeah I
[Applause]
mean he's like hi all of these girls I
don't care about make yourselves at home
you already know what a bar
is okay is that a thing they already
know where the bar is
so Skeletor would be crazy yo so crazy
wonder where the drugs went in those in
his Wolverine
hand this feels like a like a high
school party movie so kind of I don't
know how to it's so different vibe wise
I agree but I feel like it's about to
hit the fan you
know can baby these two women could just
like kill them that's true take his
apartment they're too hot though they're
just trying to get late by him and his
36 ABS I would
too he might be Purge Daddy but still
I've seen no proof except for being cute
yeah this one doesn't have a purge Daddy
they that he's just Daddy but yeah right
daddy like is Skeletor Purge
Daddy he might be
technically if you saw anybody with the
contacts you'd be so freaked out right
cuz you like you're out she's up on him
like wait is this going to change him
I'm like have you looked at his face
honey why are you dancing with
him oh no something's about to go
yeah and then there's going to be two
naked girls his going to be out and just
going to be hard to fight that way you
know when your out yeah you don't want
to be caught with your vulnerable oh
no no oh God here he
goes this is where oh no oh no oh no oh
no you were right oh no oh no
what wait how did he okay he felt it he
felt it
wow
why do they want him CU he maybe because
he's the head of the yeah they want
their like boyfriends to take over the
biz
maybe oh my God you guys like how is no
one being like if you have a contact get
out of
here
okay do these girls have contacts in no
right no but there's like everyone at
this party I'm like you guys I know I
know I'm just wondering why the girl's
doing
it oh okay you got to kill him who and
how much capital a more money than we
see in 10 lifetimes do this [__] we do
it was her way out Cherry they watching
make that money so that Soul innocent H
is he going to kill
him
oh okay buddy buddy
now you gave him your gun yeah you got
to you just dropped I'm going to find
you you guys know I hate it when
somebody leaves a weapon behind don't
like that that's a thing of yours it's a
thing of mine in movies I hate it people
are beginning to participate don't get
too excited many people are looking at
them as a gauge of the purge's success
but so far it's been relatively quiet
and that's bad because we need more
entertainment yeah and War makes money
take out all the people in The Towers
it's what the government wants hi I am
the vocal embodiment of The Purge
currently we're praying on the lower
class to support the upper class that
guy's mask was spooky yeah for sure he
get that
mother now I know everybody who is
smoking
crap yeah it's like this probably how
the government got tabs on who they
wanted dead and who the lowincome
communities are like just that's true to
just like Target them extra especially
cuz it's all being recorded and they are
microchipped probably from the covid
vaccine that was a joke she's joking you
guys I make a
y
p that got me that got
me good one that good quit while you're
ahead hey just call him to check in
how's Brooklyn how's Uncle T I'm not in
Brooklyn where are you okay I'm on my
way uh call your guy call your ex yeah
the [__] Try Us for his sake
wish he hadn't the B the fat that stayed
home that they call that guy who sent
the girls no no this is a bad call Babe
girly do you have a weapon
girl what are you cly what hey you
should be at least be walking around
with a lamp or something or tell
somebody where you're going you're above
a grate somebody's going to C get in
that
great
nope what is this
noise oh my God I hate it I hate it girl
come
on yeah kick him in the face okay so she
did at least have pepper spray thank
goodness grabing
totally that was so creepy but best line
in the movie grand
mother that's enough to make you call
your ex or turn around cuz he has you
know weapons and power and a
car
uh like what's her plan of attack where
you
at his eyes glow yeah
is that Skeletor oh he's taking it out
all right all
right call your X I'm not trying to say
that a women need a man but that in that
man in particular would be helpful in
the scenario and you're just out of the
open you're out in the open oh oh okay
see Skeletor here we are and now your
brother he doesn't have a gun or a way
to help you where's your
brother I don't want to my God shove
those needles into his
neck
okay keep stabbing come on
guys he's going to come to the
church with a knife in his
back oh [__] my girl he thinks they K
I'm the king now so tell me that [__]
ass [__] beg for his
life whoa hello young king didn't
anybody tell you a I don't know how to
die you can't Purge me man I purge you
later
a all over her nice fur coat that are
pimp B for the thing is we're supposed
to be rooting for him that's why this
movie is different we're supposed to be
rooting for him but we're not yeah it's
just hard to root for
him he is a smoke show but he's also
like really the cause of death for so
many kidss on the corners and he's
dealing we think opioids which is the
epidemic is horrible it's like I can't
just be in his Corner full no we should
have expected the unexpected this is an
experiment there are variables is this
big
brother socioeconomic group is not
reacting the way that I predicted the
NFA put a lot of faith into this evening
if it's deemed ineffective the entire
regime could be judged as a failure I
told you that science does not obey the
laws of politics there's not really
anyone we're rooting for in this movie I
mean except for her you know she's like
on the right side of church goingo Law
Abiding Citizen who didn't get chipped
when I was with Demetri I saw a lot of
stupid [__] I've been down the swoll
before and I saw a way out just let me
help you see it too what is it God de de
oh no somebody about to die uh right
there gra mother is it a doll on no
different my God I mean of course he's
got he's going to get
killed oh
wow that's the dumbest thing that you
could do because everyone else on the
street is probably going to have a
legitimate weapon and shoot you first so
that was a water G I don't know what
that guy's
thinking they're always popping wheelies
during The Purge man Purge popping Yeah
man they they Purge grabbing motor flag
that he had what is that flag yeah I
can't see it is got a a black black star
no X like or cross but shorter where the
hell did they come from what what do you
mean yeah well they you're you're in the
middle of The Purge buddy violence have
been seen wearing masks and
disguises yeah cuz like people still
might not hide you for jobs yeah totally
right just because there's not legal
ramifications doesn't mean there's not
your neighbors or yeah yeah that's
right they're saying it's not going as
according to plan do they want more
violence or what I I think they wanted
more for the lower class to just kill
the lower class out and she's going to
realize she they need the upper class to
kill the lower class is that the oh [__]
look at these crazy in the system yo
that mean that's so I guess they Persian
too yo I purge like that every night oh
no oh no oh
okay flip us
around what
the why
are he just cracked that guy's
neck who is he dude military or
something Purge Daddy yeah he has become
Purge Daddy I mean he oh he we're going
to need some help Purge Daddy's supposed
to be good but like I don't know what's
going on there it's so hard when
somebody's really hot to think of them
as anything other than good I know
struggling every day that's that me and
Roxy going through life like that
person's good-look there's no way they
can have any bad in them at all ever
that's got to be P
daddy think we found our toxic trait
yeah uh I'm
like of
course oh my
God but they're not in the contacts
either no yeah none of them are right no
okay do you think that see this is a new
founding father's esque type of group
right that like gang activity across the
island on multiple screens participation
levels increasing increasing violence on
various maybe they hired people to go do
this yeah right where are these gangs
coming from why weren't they out earlier
Islanders are now taking to the streets
as we are witnessing waves of violence
oh because he probably set those white
guys out
there left oh he said don't question for
both of us yeah that makes sense n we
can't
go her girl's going to be dead
sad sorry sorry it's okay oh god oh
bastards went inside about a dozen of
them started shooting at everyone
thought you okay I wouldn't call that
okay yeah where's theor have you stay we
don't know we don't know where she is
she left earlier she was looking for you
oh no n her phone's
off get to my apartment
now maybe that's what I would do too
just cover myself if was on the street
somebody else's blood and that way if I
saw somebody I just lay down and pretend
I'm already dead I think they would see
you do it
maybe not I could be quick so these
overseas after I enlisted they work for
anyone anywhere as long as the cash is
correct these Real Deal should we park
in Forth 10 minutes ago we need a word
for her people like her too like perge
[__] or like yeah whatever you need
access to to see where the hell they
came from Purge instigator purg
instigator purg
instigator we have a Bree inside our
private
office he's such a tool yeah I hope he
gets no ever gangs know where people are
gathering because of the tracking
implants how would gangs know how to
monitor the tracking implants yeah baby
it's come from inside you got them all
you're sending soldiers into the island
disguised its gangs as Citizens you're
making it look like people are
participating this country is
overpopulated people don't want us to
raise taxes our debt is tripled can't
pay for anything how would kill people
make more money for taxes you're trying
to depopulate the lower classes just so
the nffa doesn't have to support them
what is her moral compass at this is too
far that's so weird she's like the rest
of it was fine but you sending people in
not fine it's weird that she's even
thinking about it what have I done you
saved us what in what way this is so
weird character flaw major the American
people don't need this terribly sorry
the nffa in America will remember you
fondly no you were wrong this was a wild
deci decision and that's what pushed her
over the edge that makes no sense she
was wanting more violence she just
wanted the lwi income people to be doing
the violence I guess she just just
wanted to prove her stats right her
science right there's also she really
thought it would work a lot more
Exposition in this movie like in that
scene it was all Exposition that I was
like I think I could have done it
smarter I dying without my without my
step stool my feet are so asleep it's
just me that rest the movie like that I
literally cannot feel my feet right now
she's dying this is very lady like wait
a I'm bir mommy don't you forget
it
wow bummer we're not going home is that
a contact comment or oh yeah I mean
that's got to be the only KKK is out so
you know it's always a good sign here we
go ready to party sent via the
government they are
mercenaries doing this and then the next
year being like yes this is a good idea
again
right I don't feel as much much
intensity right now as I have in the
last ones but no or as much connection
to the storyline or characters and I
thought I would right now during this
point in time but I'm not quite there
yet like I'm rooting for them but not in
a way that makes me like they're going
to
win who that was
quick
okay oh good job okay
he's going to like throw it or something
yeah oh
whoa he looks like the guy a little bit
black phone yeah is that what you're
thinking yes Ethan honk yes island is a
war zone yes Susan the nffa had been
releasing firsthand footage from some of
the participants Imes have been coming
in at a furious at
what injured his neck the other day it
was a lot of blood I thought I cleaned
it all up look it's nothing you need to
worry about oh somebody's here I'm sorry
about my paranoia this is so crazy girl
this is not your paranoia you was a
church was attacked yeah that is crazy
to put fake blood on your body to
pretend like you were dead what they I'm
doing to this country I am worried about
this country she's about to be killed
yeah we're not going to let anything
happen to her oh no this night will not
win five 4 three
two perch go one that I got her that's
good not a fortress I went like this and
that was good she just that was good
[__] this week wow they got so many
weapons we got a big new bad from
unknown Supply they're like an army the
hell is this this is exposal devices
Purge mommy Purge Purge mommy is giving
birth in the moment there's a lot of
good people out there who we going to
have to protect now see the NFA forgot
about one thing they forgot about us uh
I think that they didn't forget about
you yeah I think they know exactly but
about protecting so here's the thing now
you are purged daddy if you go protect
people but then you have to do that
365 days a year you can't just do it on
this one day and then kill people all
the other days if you're going to be
purged daddy you got to be Purge that a
year long
yeah oh
who is this Marissa to it is I mean
that's her hair okay
yeah oh they killed her oh all right
thank you for your service now you dead
they kept calling your doctor so she's a
scientist scientist science is dead well
I guess nobody missed me huh yes oh
she's back yeah but somebody else is
inside I was scared to death out there I
lost my damn cell phone I couldn't call
nobody for help then I get the bubble
guts tried to run home that was a bad
ideaa bubble guts like diarrhea
oh but it gets better cuz I [__] on
myself a little bit when I was on the
way home oh my God love her best
character love that monologue love all
that part of that script the bubble what
was it the bubble guts I've never called
it that but I knew exactly what you
meant when she said it which is a little
sad you like it's obviously
diarrhea viin viin viin I really thought
we would be at a crescendo of of stuff
right now
[Music]
resistance against team on and B Echo
transit to assist Echo here what we're
going to do go kill the KKK members
yeah it's tough cuz they're mercenaries
and they got the
weapons I'm
here see they didn't calculate this
right because it's not poor people who
want to kill poor people it's rich
people who who want it yeah
exactly how crazy is that rich people
already have everything and yet they
still want R yeah so that they can have
more greedy little
mfers I'm out me too I'm
out no come on Purge daddy where you at
yeah show
up oh boy
yeah you guys got to stay
down why are you still popping out of
that window coming give me
one this sucks you guys are going to
die is that just fog or is it gas
gasas o yes Pur Daddy all right that was
a cool shot Purge Daddy's here to say
gangsters it's like like easy when
you're like I don't know which guys are
the bad guys or the good guys and you
show up and people are in hoods and oh
got
it this is shot really cool yeah I agree
I feel like they shot on a stage right
just the strong light the fog and no
nothing else matters cuz you're like oh
they're there the Devil Himself he shall
appear let's get these wise men some
more
weapons he's become our Purge Daddy but
like I know the the moral ground on like
what he started with is like not
just remember his abs so yeah he's got a
lot
whoa oh the DRS have
weapons
whoa
no cuz they didn't want them to save
them why would you go out they're going
to see the only
one that would be pretty devastating you
lost your whole crew there Darkest Night
of the Soul suck a goddamn arm y this is
some straight [__] that's a militia
we need to try to sneak out of here how
they're coming in through all the exits
we are not giving up there's somebody
else in their apartment for sure still
though right maybe maybe not I feel like
they would have killed him by now right
red hering they're going to move from
floor to floor killing as many as they
can okay you on a 14th floor so you got
time whoa lights are changing in here
yes they did like we both saw that
happen was it because I said something
that light continuity
issue are he listening she just starts
yelling continuity
issue all it's all not good for us today
p no no Fortress right then Fortress I
did good then I did
good
yeah you guys can't just step out like
you got to wait I would at least know to
wait till they come through the door and
you take them out one by one door door
door door door come on you guys let me
ask you this when you're going like this
the gun I know I don't know cuz you're
you're saying you're take them out and
you're doing like Simon s movements I'm
doing like you know gun gun gun gun
y'all filled the building but didn't go
in the back uh staircase obviously yes
that makes perfect sense everybody else
is here hearing this maybe leave
oh oh okay that was cool that's cool
daddy go
daddy daddy burning
the daddy daddy you are
Supreme
whoa okay there a cool little stomp
there nice I like that this shot is kept
going yeah and that's the coolest part
about this whole thing right here that
was awesome that was very cool way to do
a staircase scene I
agree maybe like rich person I feel I've
heard that
[Music]
before a mass is
freaky
oh oh Purge Daddy
yeah Purge daddy yo did we ever kill
Skeletor no okay I feel like Skeletor is
going to save somebody's life Skeletor
might be in that apartment Skeletor
might be in there that's a hand Cannon
I'm a big girl I can handle it no way
delorious have you used that gun before
I have old boyfriend she's got training
gangster training there's only five
bullets in here it beats a damn spatula
yeah he use up all you can get guys is
start blocking off the windows those a
little forced there's only five bullets
in here it beats a spatula if I if I had
the strength to hold up your foot I
would help you her foot's asleep it's
completely asleep both of them are yeah
that's good
actually aim for the neck above the
armor no who old boyfriend everybody
else in the closet like she doesn't come
on they would know a I'm not getting in
no closet I'm staying out here with you
let's do this I love her
yeah okay oh yeah that was a weird ghost
thing you think that was part of the
edit I don't know
orall weird stuff happen with the TV and
the lights in yeah and her sliding down
strange
choices okay all right kill him all
clear the left clear on right okay you
guys got this yeah okay cool cool cool
yeah yeah yeah you only have five
bullets better
serve nice I like when people stab
multiple times to make sure get back
okay who's this guy what's he got I
don't know but where is Purge Daddy
yeah also
take
what I'm confused going to be confused
about is bir's daddy she said I'm
confused do I yeah don't H well I'll be
okay yeah yeah hug him okay let's have
this conversation a different time I
wish that was just holy crap are you
okay yeah get back to work he's up here
took out half our team kill everyone on
this floor Expedition they're saying it
back there in the hallway just having a
group meeting you got to go no I'm with
you it's like we really focused on I
mean I guess the the groups kind of
merged but then all his people die I
don't know the formatting on this one's
a little wonk
yeah
[Music]
that was uh I don't know why I'm
positive but Skeletor has got to come
through what's that unless I'm just are
we forgetting that we that he died it's
very possible I thought the last thing
that we heard was him say I'll find you
when they cut him with like with the
girl when his sister came right but he
didn't die we he didn't
die I mean they're going to see the
mirror oh God that was some weird that's
an extreme weapon that they're preparing
you guys will not survive
that yeah like get out like oh Skeletor
knew it called
it look at him
go wow good job
Skeletor what oh yeah okay hey you got
you got a few in there what was that I
don't know he's got to shoot it though
he's got to hit it okay oh no he got hit
oh what a who oh
Skeletor that that's a cool shot right
there of the feet and the fire that's
some CG working in our favor right now
yeah wow what okay it wiped everything
out I don't feel that's how that would
work Jesus Christ it's not all my blood
I'll be
f is there a way to build a bomb that
has like a backdraft or you just I don't
know but then it took the bodies with it
like a time machine there was no bodies
left it just burned them all to grip did
it well we haven't gone we saw Skeletor
just get like
composed is it all of a sudden daylight
now it is almost over yeah okay the sun
is rising yeah this one countdown really
like the other ones yeah it didn't and
we needed it I also want to see if the
bodies are really like you know gone
gone or if there's some
leftovers okay Pur it's over for now for
now little do you guys know this runs
for another 20 years yeah big dog of
Park Hill is coming through I love her
me too like she's the lady you need in
your community so what do we do now
we fight did she just say what do we do
now and he said now we fight yes were
those words The Purge is over though no
I think he means like fight back against
the man the machine I get it everybody
he love died except for them yeah and
I'm wondering like why flag is a half
mask why wasn't that like why didn't she
ask him I love this song we going be all
right oh she knows
it James
Monaco okay
who Michael Bay he did the other ones
too right yeah well the turnout was
bigger than we ever expected Staten
Island have proven that this experiment
was necessary I've received word from
president Bracken that we're considering
a nationwide Purge as early as next year
he's the worst one where every US
citizen can
participate he's got such a white guy
face
too
um the biggest thing like at the end
there I thought there would be a
conference some words spoken about what
he did before Purge Daddy and where he's
going to focus his stuff now because
she's holding him up like she did not
support she didn't text him back CU she
was like you're a drug dealer and you're
putting more bad stuff in the community
then you are doing good um and we still
didn't really address that it was just
that his whole crew died died and ex
other one guy yeah and he did help them
right killing the KKK great and helping
the community in that in that way but we
didn't really address like where does
his moral code stand now because he says
we fight but I'm like does that mean
that you have left and realize like oh I
did bring wor I did make this community
worse by what I was doing and I should
have found another way it's like you
can't always you don't always have that
resolution right after you know like it
takes you a little bit to think about it
but I hear you in movie
land like a little bit something like
are you going to change a little bit
like because they're so close now
because he came to save her right I get
it but also your entire crew is dead and
you're saying we're GNA fight and I'm
like yeah okay I just there wasn't any
of that there wasn't any of it in this
that anyone was like oh we're going to
now I've changed my ways a little bit to
now go go ahead it was just sort of we
moved through the
story but nobody was really changed by
The Purge like to in
totality meta like they emotionally no
one was changed is my point like that
guy he could have said like I'm not
going to do that my whole crew is dead
the the brother is right the brother was
a little bit Yeah but not like a lot you
know I don't know I just I I think I'm
just looking for ways in which maybe
someone would have been changed in this
process in a larger way because during
the movie I didn't well the brother was
pushing and now he's not and then the
sister's she's like what do you want me
to say all these things she's like yeah
and he's like well I just did and then I
think he's going to be off the streets
but I'm with you like all the other for
sure for sure even though I did enjoy
parts of this for sure for sure this is
the weakest of the of the perch movies
so far because we don't have those
character arcs we're not like we are not
in people's Corners the same kind of way
that we were a lot of the characters
didn't have that motivation that was
clear or like that Center thing at their
core and the way that Purge daddy Frank
gillo were like okay he wants to avenge
his son's death or whatever like with um
Purge daddy in this one I'm like okay so
at your core you like this girl but what
What's your deal like what is your sit
uh but you're still like down with
getting prostitutes like and you're
still you know like it's a little yeah
it it looked good the actors are good it
sounded cool there were some cool shots
to it the premise is cool it's
interesting to go back and see the first
one I liked knowing that Marissa to's
plan didn't work because it's like you
don't eat your own you know and so that
all kind of made sense but even that I
wish we kind of don't that's me
connecting the dots I kind of wish that
they did go more into like I thought
with this socio economic class that they
would all wipe each other out they
didn't how why are my calculations wrong
and the reasons the calculations are
wrong is because it's it's the rich that
hate the poor not the poor that hate
each other exactly and like then next
year even at the end next year we need
to implement new systems where this is
cross country so that they they can be
going after each other or whatever like
right they're just you're having to fill
in a lot of the blanks with and I don't
even know if that was the intention of
this movie or if that's just me really
trying to force it you know right I mean
that that would have yeah I mean and I
guess we wouldn't have necessarily
needed to hear like oh for the next one
we definitely need to send in like white
rich instigators to start because I in
in this they're they're saying lower
class is not going to kill lower class
which I assume that would for Skeletor
except for Skeletor when you're in
throwing it off yeah when you're in a
real bad way and you're hop up on drugs
you're ready to kill some people totally
but he was ready before The Purge right
he already had cut our our guy the
brother the it it's there was a lot of
things that were going on in this while
almost nothing was going on yeah you
know like in previous ones we've had
people trying to protect their store
people trying to protect their family
people trying to protect their home you
know this it's like we were with them
yeah but again it is the first one so
nobody even knew what they were doing
fully yeah but I'm like still with story
if you're going to tell the story who
are we supposed to like really cling to
in this and it you know essentially it
would be the girl right her her moral
code was like good all along she helped
her brother and then she's probably
going to help the I forget his name but
the the druggy guy like turn his ways
and fight for a a bigger like the bigger
good drug no no no the dri yeah the
Dimitri the leader or whatever um that
she is going to help him fight for the
bigger good but I still wasn't like oh
yes you know and I want to feel that
like I just want to feel it more I I
wanted to be connected to it more and I
wasn't I still totally agree with you my
favorite shot is the one shot the one or
in a stairwell that's awesome a lot of
the stunts in this were were great the
fight scenes once they got to it um
especially him like cracking a neck yeah
I'm on board for that you don't see it
enough in movies and I'm like heck yeah
yeah that was really cool that was
awesome I um and the music was really
cool like the Music Drops are really
cool closing out with Kendrick Lamar
very good choice I think that they did a
really strong job with that the other
but going to something I also didn't
don't think that they did enough of you
are telling me you are in Staten Island
and as somebody who grew up in Boston
and I have a lot of friends from the
city and from Staten Island from I have
friends from all over New York but I
have friends that really like even if
it's not a big accent they ody Staten
Island or like I guess that they were
showing us around places but it didn't
feel like this was taking place on
Staten Island except for the fact that
they just kept telling us we're in
Staten Island we're on stat Island we're
in statan Island like like the town that
movie about Boston shows a great
representation of like no one has to say
like this is a town we're in Boston you
just get it versus they didn't they
didn't do that at all if they hadn't
kept saying we're in stat Island I don't
even think I would have picked up on the
fact that they're in Staten Island and
it's like all the the reason I think
they did that is because they it's an
island the fairy obviously like to get
people off of it it's more isolated so
it makes sense why that would be where
the first Purge was but then you need
the people to embody Staten Island I
agree and also I think that one of the
things that a lot of East Coasters take
pride in especially people from Staten
Island is like protecting your own right
so kind of lean into that a little bit
more maybe yeah but then we see the
Skeletor stuff and it does get a little
confusing yeah like if they leaned into
like stat like we're here we're in New
York this is how we this is how we are a
community and protect each other um like
they doing a lot of movies like like I
said town is a good like representation
of that uh they did a nice job with that
but um there's always good actors in
these movies though yeah I agree none
the acting bugged me at all they're all
solid it's really just the story and why
I didn't feel like I was like
you know stoked on it I I don't I missed
Frank gillow I missed P Daddy I missed
like that that connective tissue how is
it all going to connect this we knew
pretty quickly how it was all going to
connect yeah and I missed kind of having
this it be a fresh lens like well the
first one we do it in the house then we
go out into the world and then we can
kill the politicians this one was like
okay the gimmick is it's the first but
then we could have played around with
the first a little bit more too like we
didn't lean into the mares Tom stuff
enough and also we didn't lean into the
moral dilemma within ourselves like even
the question I asked you would you do
this it's a moral dilemma that every
person would have to ask yourself and I
want to see them grapple with that you
know we saw the mom and daughter kind of
grapple with but we need the money but
what about hearing from them like you
know I don't murder's still wrong this
will still affect who I am or like this
the only day I can do this you know just
any kind of actual connection to the
audience of us question ourselves would
we do this cuz that's what the movies
have done so far so I think they just
could have done a little bit better I
wonder how other people felt about this
movie where we have it pulled up on
Amazon and it looks like it has a four
and a half Stars which is that's
interesting maybe that maybe people
loved this one it didn't work as well
for me although it was still engaging
because I like the concept of The Purge
movies yeah me too and I loved all the
actors and as I said I had some favorite
shots in there which is great and I like
the way that it was shot I the only
thing that really just that bugs me is
just the story and it's not the story as
a total it's just there's Parts in it
where I was sitting here wondering why
at this point in time all the other
movies I was like what's gonna oh my God
and this one I didn't really feel that
at all because I kind of was like wait
there has to be a switch in here as we
both assumed something that surprised us
and there wasn't it just sort of
continued where we thought it was going
to go which is okay um still great
stunts and stuff like that but um the
the story for me didn't didn't really
hit it but maybe for other people they
don't really need that and I always do
there's more purges after this right we
know that there was The Purge TV show
and then there's and then I think
there's more movies right I don't know I
I wonder where they could kind of go
from here like I think they probably
will break away from this story because
this story was told in fully unless they
want to stay with Daddy on this one and
show us kind of what you wanted at the
end of this which is like did this
change your life did this affect you
where do you where you where do he go
yeah where' you go my
love so any more any more first Purge
thoughts no no you guys got it all I
didn't hate it but I didn't love it I
wish the story was better mainly I just
wanted to feel that pull a little bit
more but he's a great acting so that's
good you know I'm going to say that I
have no more thoughts on this either but
mostly because I need to get feeling
back in my feet yep and that's what
we're going to do from here so thank you
guys so much for being here to purge
with us if there are more purges and you
want to see us cover them then write so
in the comments let us know like the
video tell your friends share it all
that good stuff and then we'll see you
next time for The Purge Purge something
if it exists yeah
bye